[Música]
começa como um sonho
o mais alto ir mais depressa
ir mais longe
eu tenho o sonho de fazer viagens de
aventura e aquelas posições ea arte mãe
skol e as montanhas e tal por pêlos o
piloto caso não tem filhos tanto com
essa responsabilidade
precisamos achar que as coisas já não
tenho apreço
eu acho que essa é a diferença
e eu continuo a chatinha da província
anos do sal delas cumpriu o sonho de
viver uma aventura para o alpinista não
bastasse a motivação entrega e ao mesmo
tempo trabalhar muito treinado mexe eu
tenho mesmo que te ver com o que ficou
nós a fazer as coisas sem estarem
devidamente explorado
[Música]
uma tulipa de selma tópica disciplinada
e consistente é o segredo para o êxito
com aquele se tiver nem fiz um ano
passado fiz alguns treinos longos jogos
maratonas hoje puxaram papel do mesmo
ano
para além disso ganhar e é necessário
muito trabalho para minimizar o risco e
garantir as possibilidades de sucesso
para só que existe plena e isso é uma
coisa pra mim eu vou ter é fundamental
para conseguir ter sucesso pois nas
montanhas compuseram levantado nem
obriga uma coleira com autoridade o
obriga a manter uma intensidade atrair
uma cara que em um time grande é preciso
ter uma vez mais alguma dignidade dos
freios
isabel manuel pico o pai que eu vou
comer um elefante
agora falta só os ovos que tira quando o
time estava cansado ou seja você não
perde como fanatismo fininho assim nós
todos os dias temos uma fatia do fato
vai ver um dia com isso faltou no
entanto a informação parece uma coisa
muito grande mas como sou fã da tijuca
muito femininos todos mesmo que ele não
possui esta montanha quer fazer um
trabalho renovava quer como a maratona
quer fazer mais três ou quatro coisas eu
tenho que fazer isso eu vou fazer um
certeza disso e eu vou pra cada time
a moça tinha isso
[Música]
a pintura buscar realizar é essencial
acreditar eu não sou especialista
montani nós pela competência alpinista
kika corresponder tópico tânio e não
deixar fazer as coisas gosto do que faço
um pouco galo ao hotel terá garantia tô
torne independente anos nos albergues
com o sonho de viver uma vitória
isabel manuel toro gaga
tornou tudo isso na taxa
vocês nunca se esqueçam de noções quem
acreditar trabalhar e vencer
vocês é que mandam na bolsa portuguesa
nunca nunca visto um forte chute
[Música]
antes do final ganhamos venceu por fim o
último obstáculo para revisão mais um
sonho
fresno folgas outros homens viram e você
do que está à espera da casa
[Música]
votaram e um de nesta casa uma melhor
para você achava em e até chegar ao
confuso fiz uma série house e vou
escutar 2° daquilo que você das mais
significativas de dívida e que alguns
nós não temos a noção que nos acontecem
num momento em que nos acontecem
eu nunca na minha vida que é isso
perguntei mesmo toda a vida sim aí sim o
outro e quando andava nesta casa eu já
queria ser piloto nunca ter pensado em
montanhas de santa vivo eu vou preferir
enfim e diversos diversas casas com um
carro bomba com comuns graus e eu sempre
vejo nessa semana e quando tem acertado
escritas a tesoura equipas a jogar eu
não tinha dinheiro para saber se joga
e portanto tinha que trabalhar para
ganhar dinheiro e passar pela zaga e
choro ou pela tv
eu não lembro o nome eu não sabia muito
inglês não foi homologado voltávamos
reuniões e estrangeiras de 30 ficaram
muito empolgados em trabalhar e não era
como hoje é um crime mais difícil outra
olhada nos vimos emprego e houve um
anúncio no jornal que dizia vendedores
foram gravadas ou se como estávamos em
1981 se conhecer algum dinheiro
vamos projetar a e vou trabalhar durante
um mês para ganhar uns conta com uma
escola aqui chamadas um centro de
produção cultural que eu fazia e vender
cursos por correspondência e bater de
porta em porta pedir às pessoas para
comprarem os cursos eo mental - para ser
humilhado durante o mês de agosto no
méxico em 2011 com um olho roxo
mesmo ainda terá passado mas quando
cheguei aqui é o centro de produção
cultural e viu o time ficar ruim e às
vezes eram diferentes eram vendedores é
sim um chip que é o chip do ventura
iluminação tudo virava o tempo passar
sabem que o nosso passado rigoroso ele
estava aqui é um dia que o supervisor do
nosso grupo vem ter connosco e disse
assim eu agora vou vá um grupo com a
medalha 6 4 em 2 já tem 31 do vendedor
de fruta galera eu como diz nunca ter
mencionado a equipe montanhas mas toda a
vida eu tinha esperança em ser piloto de
pessoal estava lá era isto é capaz de
ser necessário o avião nunca tinha
andado de avião e portanto eu tenho o
meu melhor dentro deste grupo em vez de
olhar os grandes vendedores como este
tem um chip do grande vencedor você
olhar pra eu se pensarmos que não tem
que montar porque o veneno e eu fui pra
minha zona trabalho era em cascais
quem salva vidas 25 de abril 1 a 1 em
cima do avaí tem um hotel portal
cidadela em uma sorveteria e nesse dia
23 cursos de inglês por correspondência
os três bares do hotel cidadela em
cascais vender 3 conseguiu vender 5
semana é muito bom
93 cursos da manhã eu fui o melhor
vendedor
eu fui pra galera na madeira também
pratica inglês envergaram os
conterrâneos 50 contas em 1981 bateria
mas aí com 50 quando foi que os dias
para ir comprar uma moto quando eu não
comprei uma moto em segunda mão e ainda
comprar o equivalente a uma reforma que
é um jogo uma coisa pessoal de música na
altura que tem a ver com as minhas
montanhas te ver que eu consegui subir
montanhas biotechnics vocês viram aqui
primeiro que eu soube foi aquilo já uma
montanha casa a pé depois que o
aconcágua possuiu elvis elvis anos atrás
chegando sabe eu não fazia a mínima
ideia do que era chamado excelente ea
internet procurar se á nos amigos conta
mais alta do continente e nem pensar
nisso eu nunca nem vou ser capaz de
subir uma montanha de oito metros e
chutes na cabeça da água
o autor limitado
porque eu estar com o chico não sou
capaz porque eu não sei quantos anos
atrás eu pensava que nunca ia vender
nada que ganharam os contribuintes cujo
chip do vendedor o chip tem a caneta do
chip quem trabalha porque o plano de
resgate aos conterrâneos 50 quilos e
consultar a página e fiz a única coisa
que eu sei fazer
junta alguns contatos e não soltava
trabalharem menos fez um curso que se
aproxima a montanha ou renal e vou
tentar seguir o jornal o jornal e na
américa do norte a montanha que é muito
exigente do ponto de vista técnico
do ponto de vista físico e uma montanha
muito esse fria
eu vou tentar ser o jornal e vou fazer
um curso técnicas invernais a tentar
sobreviver ao eu for capaz sozinho de
natal em risco o resto fez um curso de
uma semana
a técnica na área polaca está aí a mãe
fiz o melhor que eu queria falar e fui
capaz de me perseguir seu sonho da
pastoral e vou tentar seguir às outras
depois de subir as outras montanhas ou
conselhos filho até que acabou por subir
o everest
qual é a diferença
o que mudou em mim a única coisa que me
foi atitude mental e é por isso que eu
joguei assim no final
nunca desistam nunca pensei com grau é
grande mais os graus não são grandes
demais e eu consegui o everest na fase
inicial eu venho de família público tudo
que nós fizemos para sair
o sherpa fazem coisas graves no crânio
deus quando leva 80 ou 90 quilos nas
costas que alguns meses levam os
investidores graus durante o ingresso
apenas os que realmente não leva nada
sobre as maiores tanto os graus somos
nós os queremos vocês nunca se sustém
com um dos degraus da escada escolheu
muito bem escada olhem por tamanhos
graus e vejam e tenho certeza absoluta
que vocês acreditarem que quiserem
trabalhar em muitos são capazes de
espírito que todos não admitem
suplemento em um papel que vocês acham
que eu posso fazer
outras grau muito importante que
aconteceu em que estava para criar com
vocês uma altura que eu tive na política
ativa na política partidária mas
significativa com o presidente do
sindicato de pilotos
descobri uma coisa da pior maneira
quando nós transporte público - a nossa
vida totalmente coordenava o que nós
pensamos que ninguém vê toda a gente e
quando temos dúvidas temos que pensar
muito no que temos essas regiões não
está a filmar toda a gente o nosso
passado pela gente vai andar vez criar
um entrosamento na nossa vida e hoje em
dia vocês acham que não
mas nas redes sociais tudo que vocês
fazem entrar na turma e parte desse - eu
aprendi uma coisa que é um outro grau
que eu queria transmitir o forma que eu
tenho e viver em ver com a ética e com
as opções nós fazemos a nossa vida tudo
aquilo que eu faço eu imagino a ser
filmado vai aparecer na televisão na
altura o telejornal
imaginem vocês não vou sediaria as
nossas aulas nos vossos formaturas no
vosso trabalho com graduados no vosso
futuro trabalho com graduados os vossos
pessoas sociais os credores sempre façam
qualquer coisa
imaginem a ser filmado a cena até o
final do terceiro quarto
se tiverem dúvidas é um grau como
funciona
é uma coisa que vocês querem antigamente
não venham fazer e nós vivemos aqui
dentro
todos contaminados espírito e acharmos
que vida é possível que vendo que um que
todos e todos por um e vai ser assim pro
esta nossa vida ativa se vocês têm a
particularidade viver uma época das
redes sociais em que todos todos por um
é muita raça quando a gente vai lá e
para a equipe
nós temos que usar o trabalho de
no curso o filho mais velho teve um
jovem antônio 35
segundo o colégio no ano uma festa com o
mix que morava no colégio do bruno china
e ficou tetraplégico para baixo uma vez
mais ganha ou então eu tinha e tem 200
amigos no facebook
centenas de amigos foram antônio maior
força são graus balsa naquela da era
usada para fazer aviões são graus que
não presta uma limpa no mundo de
fantasia
olhem para nossas casas eu gosto do
ponto a ao ponto e com grau sol e de sua
escolha
se eu trabalhar tenha certeza conseguir
passar tem que ter ética na forma como
tudo isso e sobretudo não vão nos graus
mais fáceis que não tem três não têm
três anos também tem um guarda na nossa
cabeça é a mensagem principal que
gostava de deixar aqui vocês é que
constroem vossas casas
vocês vão até onde quiserem ir tudo o
que fizerem você ainda faz um som com
ética e valorizar os princípios que
aprenderam na vossa vida e alguns
daqueles que me atenderam aqui mas
acreditem estão caso vocês são muito
tímidos
existe uma gigantesca escala volta do
colégio
vocês vão ter contração de atenção em
qualquer coisa
[Música]